hey what's going on Jesus listen to my
voice here it's bill burr and it's time
for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday August 19th 2019 what's going on
how are ya I'm fighting off a cold here
Oh [ __ ] Billy Flanders Oh William know
vice you know not drink head not spoke
at cigars not joy in life and now look
at me I get a goddamn cold you know from
running around doing nothing I got I've
actually been like looking up pictures
of cigars online since I've decided that
I'm gonna lay off them for a while and I
think that's when you know you have some
sort of addictive problem you know if
you lay off heroin you start looking up
pictures of spoons sorry it's early in
the morning I actually I'm not as sick
as I sound right now but anyway anyway
old Billy's back in LA the big Hollywood
phony came back to town right before
this city got some credibility and I
dragged him right back down into the mud
I am beyond excited I have nothing to
[ __ ] do and I'm gonna keep it that
way for a while I'm just gonna chill out
you know anticipating the beginning of
the NFL whup up up football season very
excited to watch Tom Brady try to go for
number seven I just paused there for all
you [ __ ] Brady hate his big [ __ ] that
guy he's a [ __ ] cheater
yes he's better-looking and he'll
achieve more this season than you ever
will in your life so you know you're
just gonna have to take that all right
did you just punch your dashboard it
isn't true I'm ethical we played flag
football
for our company picnic in July and I
told the cornerback on the other team
that his shoe is untied I am a better
person maybe you are but you're not
better-looking Tom Brady will always
have that on you all right just [ __ ]
with you
by the way I finally got all caught up
on my MotoGP season I watched the last
two races and if you ever thought about
getting into racing if you just want to
have something cool to talk about with a
lovely lady within your vicinity and you
think hey maybe if I talk really loudly
about motorcycle racing she'll be like
oh my god who is that you know and then
you could have Tom Brady's life - this
great looks right
get yourself lovely lady you got to
watch MotoGP it's the best [ __ ]
racing out there [ __ ] those pickup
trucks [ __ ] stock car racing [ __ ]
Formula One [ __ ] everything this is the
best [ __ ] Ninja Warrior
all right [ __ ] the next presidential
race the best [ __ ] race out there
[ __ ] this space race all right [ __ ] the
lobbyists MotoGP is where it's at you
got to watch this last one from Austria
it's Spielberg all right the two top
racers Andres Davitt CEO so and Marc
Marquez had like a race that you put in
a [ __ ] Hollywood film like the last
couple laps specifically the last lap
itch and they've done it but they've
done it like three [ __ ] times just
the two of them [ __ ] divisio so
coming on the brakes late right [ __ ]
bastard Marquez and then Marquez would
undercut him coming out of the turn they
did that I lost count how many times
they did that and then they get to the
final [ __ ] turn I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm selling this sport here spoiler
alert final [ __ ] turn it looks like
Marquez has it one
onda hasn't ever were a marques has
never won their the Ducatis just
dominate for whatever reason in Austria
and it looks like he's gonna finally win
they're coming out of the final turn
individ co so [ __ ] passes him and you
see the frustration of marques he did
like a [ __ ] wheelie like [ __ ] like I
had the guy you gotta watch the replay
because since this guy who looks like
he's like 80 years old in the part of
the the pit crew or the racing team of
Ducati and he's going [ __ ] it he looks
like me the first time I went to an
ac/dc concert and I couldn't believe I
was in the same building I was like
[ __ ] 80 jumping up and down slapping
the got this other guy on his back going
[ __ ] nuts it's just the best racing
out there I still have questions you
know that I need answered being you know
I'm not a gearhead I'm more of a Jiffy
Lube guy that's my pit crew I go to
Jiffy Lube this is what I don't
understand as far as Suzuki goes I don't
get why they are so underpowered like
whenever they get on this straightaway
if they're winning
if somebody's you know divisio so on is
uh what the [ __ ] is driving there's
Ducati and Marc Marquez on his Honda
they just blow by him like they're on a
regular Street bike I don't get that I
know certain teams have more money or
whatever all right but Valentino Rossi
rides a Suzuki what is he right on a
yamaha yama is the same [ __ ] problem
I think it runs a Yamaha I don't [ __ ]
get it like just the amount of t-shirts
and hats the merch that Rossi still
[ __ ] selves you know what do you
don't have as much horsepower as those
so you lighter so you're more nimble in
the turns is that why they do it I can
you know as a [ __ ] novice I could
tell you that strategy isn't working
can anybody explain that to me
for the love of God can you help a
[ __ ] guy who goes to Jiffy Lube
figure that out but um anyway the next
race is on August 25th in Britain all
right Lewis Hamilton's [ __ ] home
ground there I imagine it might be the
same track he always seems to win there
over there in Formula One not [ __ ]
on formula why shouldn't it form the one
because I still like Formula One but uh
I would I can't recommend enough going
to the Moto G website signing up you can
watch all the races this year and you
can watch races in the past which I've
been doing I watched one from 2002 and
and there's great one from 2001 where
the track was so wet they were going
around turns it looked like when I took
the motorcycle safety course the way I
first started taking turns I mean
they're literally almost upright been
watching this guy Biagio or something
like that he was one of the great guys
back then I had heard his name so I'm
getting to see and it's also great just
to see motorcycles with like cigarette
companies you know the old Marlboro ones
like they's be a big one back in the day
or Harry Gant with the skull bandit car
right had [ __ ] tobacco I mean it was
the [ __ ] that was like the perfect
storm of [ __ ] just redneck stock car
racing [ __ ] bring your own bear
welcome race fans and he's in his number
one sponsor is [ __ ] chewing tobacco
you know that's the America that I
remember make America great again
let cigarette companies get back into
racing I know I know I was actually
looking at followed Dean Del Ray on
Instagram and he took this thing I mean
I'm not a cigarette smoker I'm a cigar
smoker but uh I didn't realize packs of
cigarettes are like [ __ ] over $12
each I still don't understand how crime
is going down all those [ __ ]
everybody just vapes now cuz I went to a
cigar store and I'm standing in line
like look at all these young kids gonna
[ __ ] by some stogies
you know who
that generation Z and generational
millennial whatever you call them are
all this big [ __ ] problem you know
and then they just wallow in their
buying like vape juice can I get the
mango [ __ ] tango thing whatever it is
aren't you kids worried about that
popcorn long no well let me wag my old
[ __ ] index finger at you you kids
need to stay away from that [ __ ] as I
[ __ ] smoke cigars like Cuba just
reopened for free trade Oh an
international joke Jesus bill it's
probably incorrect you know you made an
attempt I made an attempt at it um yeah
so what do you been doing bill with all
your free time no call time no call time
oh thing of beauty I decide when I get
up while my kid does but whatever I've
just been hanging out with my kid having
a great time you know it so gonna go
ride some she likes riding the ponies
she doesn't bet on the pony she likes
riding the ponies took her on a
merry-go-round
we've been going swimming just having
the best time ever starting the day with
the smoothie you know big la phony I
have a smoothie that's what I do I eat
well for like a couple days in a row and
then I just have a [ __ ] you know I
have one of those meals that makes the
American Heart Association be like well
it looks like we're still gonna be a
business we can still send out our
[ __ ] warnings but it seems to be
working for me laying off the but a
right now I um I think all my [ __ ]
when I was old Billy fat face Billy fat
again
Billy McFadden I was uh it was all booze
because I'm still you know I'm eating
pretty good I mean pretty good but I'm
still [ __ ] you know I'm getting after
the burgers and the pizza here and I
don't tell you my [ __ ] pasty torsos
looking all right it's looking all right
hmm so speaking of which 200 and [ __ ]
60 something days no booze through 66
right is that what it was to 66 67 - 68
268 [ __ ] days 38 weeks in I'm getting
down to the homestretch of taking a
[ __ ] year off you know well I'm gonna
go right through December because I
always wanted to go January 1st to
December 31st then I was thinking I'd
also like to go an entire birthday like
I never drank when I was 51 so then I'd
have to go to June and next year which
at this point it's not that bad
it's nice and easy you know I haven't
had to apologize for any [ __ ] up thing
I said or how late I stayed out can you
hear the crushing mind-numbing boring
boredom of not [ __ ] drinking I'm
getting eight hours late doing crossword
puzzles again I did play like four hours
of drums over the last two days
getting back into that actually playing
on a drum kit having a [ __ ] great
time that's it and tomorrow I'm gonna be
up in San Francisco at the punch line
because the punch line needed saving
it's one of my favorite comedy clubs in
the world and they work they lost their
lease they were gonna shut it down so I
said well goddamn and I'm gonna get up
there and get another [ __ ] night in
before they shut down and the whole
thing was gonna have a sad ending and
then Dave Chappelle showed up with a
cape on and talked to the president of
[ __ ] San Francisco and he talked him
into not closing it down so they didn't
lose their lease but I'm still going up
there anyway I used to go up there and
work out new material on Mondays morose
Mondays I'd go up there and work it out
just having at the time so I'm heading
back up there tomorrow with Joe bartnik
the guy where I met Joe bartnik the
mid-2000s the first time I went up there
in a headline Molly paired me up with
him and literally 90 seconds into
watching his ass
that was like I [ __ ] love this guy so
we're gonna be doing it again that's
gonna be tomorrow night and then I think
my next date is September 6th in Las
Vegas and then I'm gonna hang around for
an extra day to go see Elton John
because I know he's on his final tour
that's been going on for like [ __ ]
nine years or something but you know
he's getting up there want to make sure
I go see that guy and that's it I think
I just have information for you this
week
you know Red Sox are they hanging in
there when I get in there like six and a
half back on a wild card I don't know
I'd take a hell of a [ __ ] last five
weeks to overcome that so I don't know
we shall see the Yankees now had the
best record in the American League what
does that mean though it's just a
regular season how many times can they
beat the Orioles I think the Orioles
didn't beat him once this year and I got
news for you Yankee fans all right but
just as a sports fan and someone who
doesn't have irrational hate for other
teams like the Yankees I don't really
even hate the Yankees I hate their fans
and the only reason why I really hate
their fans is because I lived in New
York City during the height of the curse
of the babe so you know most of my
friends were comedians and Yankee fans
and I'll just say that they were not
nice but I am a fan of the success of
that franchise you have to respect it
you just have to so as mentioned that
this is the last year of this decade
they have to win the title this year to
continue a ridiculous streak that nobody
can touch even if they don't win it is
they would have won at least one World
Series in the in the last hundred years
every single decade except for the 1980s
all right they won like [ __ ] three or
four 96 98 99
they won 2000 2009 nothing in the 80s
they
77 and 78 then when a couple to three at
the beginning of the 60s and then 30s
40s and 50s they won five six or seven
it seemed let's look up the [ __ ]
Yankee titles man even as a Red Sox fan
I mean you got to give it up you got to
give it up even almost those Yankee fans
[ __ ] won't give it up to the Patriots
because that's just how they are a bunch
of spoiled kids all right I just love
starting [ __ ] on people alright let's
look up New York Yankees alright New
York Yankees yet Cleveland Peter meets
before last night everybody's sleeping
on Terry Francona Terry Francona not a
joke can he bring them a championship
the way Theo Epstein left the Red Sox
the curse Keller Theo Epstein curse to
the goat curse to the babe he bully gave
both of them the old [ __ ] and right
there Fred all right
World Series titles oh my god I gotta
get out my glasses I don't have glasses
yet I need him though alright so in the
60s they won one in 61 and 62 and the
1950s they won 1950 51 52 53 and 56 and
58 they won 6 World Series in the
[ __ ] 50s the 40s they won 41 43 47
and 49 they won 4 and helped to win a
world war in the 30s they won 32 36 37
38 39 they won 5 the 20s 23 27 and 28 so
they in the 20s they won 3 they won 5 in
the 30s for in the 40s and 6 in the 50s
that was it it's like Mack Marquez when
he gets out front and it did a couple of
races this year right there you go this
the motorcycle version up and he just
[ __ ] decides like I don't feel like
dealing with you [ __ ] for the rest
of this race and within [ __ ] 10 laps
he has like a [ __ ] 10-second lead
here and then they came back down to
earth in the 60s and only one too and in
the 70s only one to 1-0 in the 80s came
back with a vengeance in the 90s I mean
that's [ __ ] amazing 27 world series
tile 40 American League pennants I got
to give him a little [ __ ] about the
pennants basically back in the day
winning the pennant all that meant was
you had the best record in the American
League there was no playoff playoffs
there was no place let's see many teams
they were back then
19km lb 1930 standings it was like like
12 teams I think all right the American
League let's see here
1930 major league baseball standings
much of a [ __ ] nerd am i all right
there was 16 team so there was eight and
eight so there's no reason for like a
bunch of rounds of playoffs okay he had
the Philadelphia Athletics I believe the
st. Louis Browns who later became the
Orioles unless Baltimore's there Jesus
cry for these [ __ ] abbreviation the
Washington Senators the Chicago White
Sox Chicago Cubs the New York Giants New
York Yankees the Brooklyn Dodgers to
Cleveland Indians the Pittsburgh Pirates
Detroit Tigers BSN who the [ __ ] is that
st. Louis Cardinals yeah they did that
the st. Louis Browns the [ __ ] is BS n
Cincinnati Reds one of the oldest teams
along with the Phillies and the Boston
Red Sox wait a second who the [ __ ] is BS
n the Boston Braves oh yeah so there was
only 16 teams so it was 8 & 8 so if you
just if you won the American League then
you won the pennant back then I don't
know when they had the first the first
time
they had the rounds of playoffs but I
mean it is what it is I mean they have
more [ __ ] teams you know you got to
have more rounds of playoffs but that's
what I don't like when I watch like
[ __ ] these sports networks and I'll
have some punk kid he just recorded the
most wins ever in a player in a year
play up I mean for you you start talking
about forever and you start thinking of
some of those names you could really
appreciate what they're looking now they
play more [ __ ] games all of this [ __ ]
alright they [ __ ] and then and then
you got on the other side where there's
less where you guys would sit there
telling me about how the Atlanta Falcons
were the [ __ ] best defense the 77 or
something like that they only [ __ ]
played 14 games the regular season -
less [ __ ] games yet they're gonna
give up less [ __ ] yards all right you
want to go average still you're playing
two less games that's two less games the
offense is completely [ __ ] changed
you like how I just acted like you guys
argued that [ __ ] point nobody ever
argue at that point I just made that up
and you know what goddamnit the
president could do it then sell the
[ __ ] eye makeup whatever the [ __ ] I
want [ __ ] sitting here down in my
basement all by myself
podcasting you don't think I'm gonna go
a little bit crazy here drinking
emergency I'm not gonna lie to you when
I first started talking on this podcast
I was a little frightened about the
sound of my voice you know hey do you
think you know you're possessed when you
get [ __ ] possessed like where do you
go when the devil possesses you where
does the person go that's like when you
black out you like you went to bed but
somebody else kept walking around as you
talking to people saying all those
things you know you gotta get your ideas
out there man that's what black out you
does you gotta tell everybody what
you're thinking man free yourself up
uh this gonna be the dumbest search ever
where do you go when you're you know
somebody answered this is why I love the
Internet
the Internet is awesome this is where
all the answers are you know I'm not
saying they're right but you there's an
answer to every single question you have
factual or most likely not okay where do
you go when you're possessed by the
devil how to tell if you're possessed by
a demon well I think the fact if you're
searching for this you're not possessed
you're probably just an [ __ ]
all right how to tell if you're
possessed by a demon Jesus Christ I got
to tell you guys what sort of
advertising I'm gonna get alright how to
tell if you're possessed by a demon
reveals Exorcist a famous Exorcist
reveals how to tell the difference
between possessed and having other
afflictions well that's a nice way of
saying just being an impossible [ __ ]
alright certainly you likely don't
believe in the possibility of demonic
possessions can the internet just get to
the [ __ ] answer and nowhere is that
more true than when you look up like a
[ __ ] recipe how to make french toast
right rather than just cut to the chase
that's be like you know breakfast was
such a big thing in our household when
growing up the sound of the bacon
crisping in the [ __ ] frying pan the
Peter patter of our feet I don't need to
hear the sound of your [ __ ] pajamas
pant legs swishing down the [ __ ]
stairs what do you do you got vanilla in
there you got cinnamon just [ __ ] cut
to the chase I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is about food people in general when
you watch like the Food Network like
first of all there's no happy medium
over there it's either like a redic
ridiculously short amount of time to
prepare something with one third of the
[ __ ] ingredients that you need just
the most stressful [ __ ] thing ever
which cooking is not supposed to be it's
supposed to be relaxing
it's supposed to be lovely it's supposed
to bring people together right or do
they have these weird just [ __ ] you
know those food channel [ __ ] songs
where it's just like literally it's like
how [ __ ] white are you that that's
that you heard that music in your head
how many times have you not been pulled
over how many times have you not read on
can spit up on conspiracy theory or even
remotely paid attention to what the [ __ ]
we're doing to this planet that you can
still hear music like that that you
could sit down and write something like
that like when I think of my [ __ ]
utopia the perfect [ __ ] planet which
if any way even remotely honest with
yourself it would be oppressive to other
people to live in your perfect planet
you know but that's not how human being
brains work you go oh my [ __ ] perfect
planet you know there'd be no war
there'd be no racism there'd be no
homophobia everybody would get a [ __ ]
chance yeah but we'd still have to
listen to your [ __ ] music alright I
actually argue right now [ __ ] I'm
gonna introduce this argument right now
right off the top of my head I think
right now we're living in a [ __ ]
utopia this is a good as good as it
[ __ ] gets you know what I mean a ham
and cheese sandwich is only gonna be so
[ __ ] good and that's what we are
we're not special okay God didn't make
us in his [ __ ] image unless he's a
[ __ ] alright
anybody out there who has a [ __ ] food
blog I know you're just doing those
stupid [ __ ] stories because you have
to fill up a certain amount of space I
actually have empathy for food bloggers
this is how evolved I am as a human
being this is how hard I'm patting
myself on the back right now this is the
greatest thing about doing a podcast by
yourself you can just heat compliments
on yourself and just feed your [ __ ]
ego before any of your loved ones get up
and you're already down the [ __ ] road
of you alright cruising down me
Boulevard
alright this letting everybody know
what's good you know breakfast
it's just thought you to pull off just
ever you just [ __ ] you know you watch
those [ __ ] goddamn shows they always
have like some sort of [ __ ] fresh
flowers you know no sign of domestic
violence
no sign of [ __ ] any like even even
lint in the carpet perfect bowls and
glasses Jesus Christ you think you think
there's any correlation to the amount of
psychos out there killing all of these
[ __ ] peoples that you haven't you
noticed that as the Food Network got
more and more popular people went postal
more and more you know you got all these
[ __ ] fat chicks out there bitching
about women who take care of themselves
and go to the goddamn gym and make the
sacrifice nobody wants to eat a salad
alright these women are out there doing
it and these fatties who got no [ __ ]
discipline they [ __ ] complain their
way onto billboards in the movies when I
when I was a kid they were in the
shadows that [ __ ]
I think I think the Food Network I think
if the Food Network had you know just
the occasional [ __ ] dirty dish or
maybe just maybe a little more
melancholy in some of the [ __ ] music
there wouldn't be so many people
snapping out there that's just a theory
I never took any criminal justice course
all right but you're listening to this
podcast most likely on the Internet okay
and the Internet is nothing but answers
okay and people are out there asking
that question and I'm here to offer an
answer without any research without any
that that's what the internet is answers
without research unless you're going for
easy ones like you know two plus two
[ __ ] that we can all agree on anyways I
don't know if you're possessed by the
devil how to become possessed by the
devil keep watching the [ __ ] Food
Network just going back and forth
between oh my god everything's great
with this [ __ ] music - holy [ __ ]
there's not enough time to make this
Ruben I don't I don't have the
ingredients I need certainly you likely
don't believe in the possibility of
Deamonte demonic possession and think
it's the stuff of Hollywood movies but
it may also be that you've never been
possessed by the devil where they gonna
say here it may also be that you don't
really know how to recognize being
possessed I present doubt sell me this
car to remedy this one of the world's
leading exorcists just shared some of
his knowledge oh you mean the guy who
makes money off of people believing
that's this [ __ ] actually exists who
the foot they were named the most
beautiful twins in the world wait
see them today what is wrong with the
[ __ ] Internet I'm [ __ ] sitting
here reading about trying to find out if
I'm possessed by the devil and then they
got to [ __ ] six-year-old girl models
what do they look like today
he's just Christ haven't we already seen
this we saw this with the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] twins they're from that show
with like day like nineteen dead they
just rebooted it full house there's like
a [ __ ] army barracks with moose I
think those like one adult woman on that
show all right father
Cipriano DeMeo you know what actually
believe who's been been an exorcist
since 1952 I would love to see an
exorcist in 1952 they just shaken you by
your shoulders as they [ __ ] backhand
slap you chrissake get all yourself
alright he revealed to the Italian
Catholic news agency as a [ __ ]
reputable [ __ ] group of people that
the key to telling whether you're
possessed or suffered from some other
possible mental illness I can't even
make the joke here because it's just not
funny what those people did is in your
reaction to the Exorcist himself and the
prayers being offered or maybe you just
[ __ ] having a good time man that
would be you know that would be the
ultimate [ __ ] prank to call up and
say you know that my my buddies
possessed by the devil and then just see
if your buddy could sit there flipping
around the bed speaking in that deep
voice and if he could keep a straight
face and then what you do is you have
the devil leave you right and then you
leave the priest happy like wow man
that's like my best whatever you know in
the
you're doing dishes trying to make your
kitchen look like you're on the Food
Network he specified that the exorcist
will usually say a prolonged prayer to
the point where if the adversary is
present there's a reaction yeah
it's called get to the point a possessed
person has various general attitudes
towards an exorcist this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] somebody's not religious who is
seen by the adversary as an enemy ready
to fight him yeah well maybe he was a
[ __ ] altar boy and he got his [ __ ]
little kilt lifted up the adversary as
you might imagine is the demonic
presence if you are possessed you are
likely to experience a very unsettling
reaction to the Exorcist prayer Oh God
do it can I read it
let's see fun father DeMaio described it
like this there's no lack of frightening
facial expressions threatening words or
gestures I've heard it all man and other
things but especially blasphemies
against God and our lady
I wonder if after you've presented an
exorcist when somebody flips out
screaming at you and traffic if you're
able to keep your cool because it's like
oh that's nothing that guy's on like a
four okay lady you want to see a [ __ ]
tent come to work with me someday all
right basically you know something suit
something seriously wrong has taken over
you how many of these people just had
like mental illness you might be
skeptical whether a possession can exist
at all and your skepticism is justified
oh that's good you're welcoming
criticism I will continue reading the
Catholic Church also takes seriously the
possibility that most people with the
possession like affliction would not
necessarily be possessed well it's nice
you guys take something seriously in
pedophilia we don't take that too
seriously but might just exhibit
disturbing symptoms chances are you will
never see
truly possess person yourself now where
are we going look at this old
[ __ ] he said I said I command
you in the name of God and through the
power of Padre Mateo I got to be honest
with you the devil is a little [ __ ]
weak if just some old guy can come in
with a couple of [ __ ] trinkets and
say I command you the power of Christ
compels you you know I don't understand
why the devil isn't just like you
realize those are just man-made things
that you put together those are clearly
two sticks of the same size put together
perpendicular you know if you hold it
the other way it's kind of looks like an
X doesn't it oh my god is that a
lowercase T with a half-naked person on
it you know when the devil just say [ __ ]
like that
sorry all right I think it's time I
think enough with the exorcism [ __ ]
let's go let's uh well let's let's read
some advertising here oh look who it is
yet about me undies me undies the devil
is in my pants - do do do me undies me
undies I need an exorcist give me a
chance
shake that cross at my balls watch Satan
run down the halls oh your balls will be
soft and the devil won't be Enya and
you'll have an angel on your taint all
right me undies is here to change your
underwear is not literally but it's here
to change the way you think about it
they believe undies shouldn't take
themselves too seriously they believe
undies shouldn't be soft it should be
soft fit everybody like it was made for
every booty and other fun patterns that
give you the freedom to express yourself
don't go for
put your [ __ ] wacky underwear on new
women's products buy me undies the
undies also believes that every woman
should also have the freedom to wear
whatever cut they want and whatever
color they want and whatever size they
want so ladies rejoice this is how free
women are right now you know I mean this
they're running out of things to
complain about that they should just
have whatever color underwear that they
want I'll tell you you know I'm all for
freeing the ladies but we freedom to
much I would say 1961 we had it right
all right
you still didn't let her drive voting
was still a novelty and you know you
came home like Fred Flintstone they had
dinner on the table there's been too
much of an overcorrection I feel you
know in 2020 if elected I I say that we
oppress women a little more I say it's
time to dial it let's make men great
again
let's make men the king of their castles
are there split entries all right me
undies also believes that every woman
should have the freedom okay so ladies
rejoice the feel freak the feel free
collection is here the undies size
tested these five new silhouettes on
every body type see that's the problem
they are a subsets of those five
silhouettes and somebody is going to be
left out they're gonna have saggy
underwear and it's just gonna remind
them that their booty isn't one of the
five silhouettes that me undies
acknowledges what about they booties
with an ultra soft feather-light
waistband that provides zero restriction
these undies will be the best thing that
has ever been on your body offered in
size it extra small to 4 XL
the undies has a great offer from my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you can get 15% off and free shipping
this is a no-brainer especially because
they have 100% satisfaction guarantee to
get your 15 to get 15% off your first
pair free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com slash
bird that's me unease calm / / hey do
you think anybody's ever lost so much
weight that they were then able to like
so their own underwear together and make
like a tent because like now they're
into hiking you know I could fit three
of me and my old underwear and that's
why I sewed three of my old BVDs
together they still got the skid marks
on them which scares away the Bears I've
never felt more happy healthy I just
keep eating beans by myself in the woods
in my tent underwear my underwear I made
out of tent my tent made out under way
there we go know if you're fat if you're
fat this is the difference between being
fat and in shape alright if you're fat
your underwear is made out of a tent if
you're in shape your tents made out of
your old old underwear does that make
sense
alright oh look who's here huh today's
show is brought to you by honey don't be
like that the easiest way to save money
when you're shopping online honestly
before you found out about honey
seeing the promo code box at the
checkout stressed you out like should
you be typing I'm just saying that
because they're saying I honestly before
I found out about hunt about honey
seeing promo code the promo code box at
the checkout stressed me up it stressed
me out cuz I don't know how to do I
don't have to [ __ ] do anything on
computers
I had the Lincoln I wanted to upload the
whole the last lap of that MotoGP race
from Steel bag and I couldn't figure out
how to do it so why should honey be
anything different anyways like should I
typing something in there is there a
code just knowing that there could be a
discount out there made me worry about
overpaying every time I shopped online
why are they making me out like I'm some
penny pinching little piece of [ __ ] out
here I'll have you some know something
honey
I pay full price for [ __ ] everything
because I don't have the [ __ ] time to
figure this [ __ ] out but my listeners do
alright stop speaking for me thankfully
now I have honey it's a free tool that
connects to your computer's browser as
you're shopping it scans the internet
for coupon codes and other discounts
then like magic it automatically applies
the best one to your cart at checkout
well figure out we'll find you every
coupon code sale or discount on over
20,000 sites like Amazon j.crew eBay
Macy's Sephora I want to know what that
is
Nordstrom and more what's Macy's Sephora
Macy's Sephora not just Macy's Macy's
before we got your back so you might ask
how do I know has my back does it really
work well not only did honey test over 1
billion promo codes last year but it
actually saved it actually applied 185
185 million 67,000 86 working codes to
people's orders that's a lot of real
life savings not to mention over 10
million people are already saving with
honey and it has well if ten million
people are doing it they all saved about
18 bucks each
so what it comes down to something like
that 185 million I think that's right
I'll wait well let's see here 1 million
times 100 yeah is that right
now I can't figure out I I can't do that
math and my [ __ ] in all right daddy's
have an aneurysm all right are saving
with honey and has over 100,000
five-star reviews on the google chrome
store
look there's no there's really no reason
not to use honey it's free to use and
easy to installing computer in just two
clicks never overthink the promo code
box again get honey free and join
honeycomb / / that's join honeycomb / /
honey online savings simplified alright
now for all you people out there alright
this is off the grid here
if something's free they got to make
money somehow right how else would they
be making their money you don't got to
be a genius to figure that one out okay
so if you're fine with that then by all
means start saving alright Barney
yo Billy Squier did you see Bernie
Sanders on Rogan
no I didn't Joe Rogan had Bernie Santa
dude the weather was [ __ ] amazing
do you know I used to do his podcast
when it was just in his house you know
sitting around a [ __ ] table now he's
having possibly the next president in
the United States Marc Maron had a
standing president that's [ __ ]
incredible
hell of an interview I would imagine I
guess what I'm gonna be doing after this
I'm gonna be watching that episode I'm
more of a libertarian slash Democrat
myself and I was impressed people were
praising it for days but of course the
news media didn't cover it of course
they don't
however when Fallon has Alec Baldwin on
the couch saying something edgy it makes
the 7 o'clock news and the CNN banner
yeah that's because Alec Baldwin cannot
affect real change so they act like oh
this is the problem over here so you
don't look at the real thing it's genius
anyway anyways I like how you wrote it
the way I said it it's funny how the all
how all the all the liberal out
have been pushing Joe Biden and other
candidates no one gives a [ __ ] about
like Kamala I locked up half I looked I
locked up half the black guys in
California Harris I don't know who that
is
Bernie is the only candidate that can
beat Trump and the people behind the
scenes of the Democratic Party are
throwing the whole fight because I think
they want to lose they don't want to
lose what they have to do is they have
to have a made guy that's what they have
to [ __ ] do that's the amazing thing
about Trump is you had a guy who was not
a made guy got in there which makes me
actually think that they do count the
votes the fact that he got in there I
think the last election um was the
reaction to the the 2008 financial
meltdown and all these people were
upside down in their house with no hope
of the American Dream and Donald Trump
tapped into that and Hillary Clinton was
a bad matchup because she was more the
same another company man with corporate
money falling out of her [ __ ] pockets
not saying Trump is an honest person I'm
just saying what he represented and what
he was selling
I feel like Bernie was a better thing
and all that [ __ ] that when Trump
won people saying that this was you know
a bunch of racist white people taking
their country back was one of the
dumbest things it was just like where
were all those racist white people when
the previous two elections they could
have voted against a black president
they took those elections off and
decided that you know they hated white
women more or something like that
although this is all [ __ ] it was all
[ __ ] I love Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders actually seems to care about
regular people and for the life of me
listening to people I don't get how the
more informed you get in politics the
more you're driven away from a guy like
him
and then you start saying things like oh
you're throwing your vote away oh by
voting for a guy who wants to hold
bankers accountable a guy wants to get
out of these [ __ ] never-ending Wars
that are bankrupting this country you
know for as much as people fall all over
themselves about [ __ ] Obama I mean
that guy [ __ ] did more drone bombings
than anybody else he was a company man
and he's out there getting his [ __ ]
kickbacks on his speech tour oh is that
another bank that was responsible for
the 2008 meltdown why absolutely I'll
give you guys a speech and won't call
you out on your [ __ ] and take your
300 grand [ __ ] all of those people
anyway Bernie Sanders is the only
candidate that can be Trump and people
behind the scenes of them throwing the
fight because I think they want to lose
I don't think that's what it is it's
just that they're grossly underpaid and
how the system works is then that these
corporations they get you into office
and then you own favors if you give them
their favors then you get to go in the
speech tour and they wash their bribe
money by grossly overpaying you for a
speech they're not going to listen to
right if you go against them back in the
day you got a convertible ride in Dallas
a crazed lone gunman would conveniently
come out of the woodwork and [ __ ]
take you out and the message was sent
all right the message was sent in the
60s okay black white male a female if
you step out of line and you [ __ ] with
these people's skin a crazed lone gunman
is going to come out of nowhere and
conveniently take you up that's it and
nowadays I think that they just because
of the deregulation of media ownership
they don't have to take you out anymore
they can just not cover you and if they
don't cover you then that's it it's like
you're in the race but you're not in the
race and that's it anyway she says it
gives them four years this is this guy's
theory and that was just my [ __ ]
theory what the [ __ ] do I know I can't
even read out loud
okay so spare me your anger okay just
listen to what I have to say and if it
doesn't make sense to you just [ __ ]
move on all right it gives them four
years too real
we have a candidate who will swing the
other way if you were Bernie how would
you get the nation's attention start
naming bankers no I would be doing what
he's doing
Bernie Sanders on the Joe Rogan podcast
is perfect Joe Rogan is a man of the
people okay if you listen to his podcast
the guy legitimately seems to give a
[ __ ] about people in their health and
he's telling him stuff that he's doing
and how he's trying to make his self his
life better Bernie Sanders is sort of
like the political version of that so I
think he goes there he gets to his ideas
well maybe that's too much of a similar
audience I don't know but I think he
goes to the people which is podcasting I
think that's maybe how he does it but
you know you watch how little coverage a
guy like that is gonna get and like Joe
Biden Jesus Christ I mean I mean that's
like the old school like when the mob
was running boxing and someone would
just take a [ __ ] dive I mean that's
just the worst [ __ ] I don't know what
guy running around like he's in a
shampoo commercial smelling everybody's
[ __ ] hair like this guy's gonna go
I love how just little things like that
can take you out of the race you know
yeah Howard Dean get too excited all
right prison guard writing in oh Jesus
okay dear bill this has got to be one of
the scariest [ __ ] jobs you could ever
have prison guard no weapon walking
amongst [ __ ] murderers and rapists
I'm a prison guard in the Northeast I've
been a fan of yours since the early 2000
and I see you anytime you're in my area
I've been a prison guard for 24 years
this April and in my opinion Jeffrey
Epstein did not commit suicide alone
holy [ __ ] oh my god here we go he either
had help or was murdered
to start not many men or women who
haven't been exposed to prison culture
would not know how to use the few
materials they're left with in a cell to
commit suicide all right
to play devil's advocate this guy also
figured out how to be a billionaire on
his own island and be the pedophile dr.
Moreau
so I mean this guy seems if he had a
goal he seems to know how to do it I
know isn't hanging yourself by your
bedsheets pretty [ __ ] standard and
him even if he was smart and had done
his research he would not have had
enough time based on the records they
released I've been in charge of suicide
watch for certain people of interest
over the years none of them come close
to Epstein on any scale of importance
and none of them were ever treated as
casually these presenting a strong
argument here about that you can do I
can get swayed easily here we go the
idea that things got relaxed enough for
this to happen
comes from anyone who's never been in or
worked in a prison I'm not saying aliens
did it but whoever carried that out made
the right bet that the public would have
no choice but to accept it first suicide
at that prison in 40 years
I appreciate you being a contrarian and
I'm not calling you names like last
week's listeners but on this one it's
small part to a larger ring of
pedophilia and I hope public and a and
authorities take the investigation
seriously well Jesus Christ shut them
shut my mouth down everybody do you see
when you present your opinion like this
without the name-calling I'm open to it
even even still even if he called me a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's the fact that he's a
prison guard trumps everything that I'm
saying
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] nuts Jesus
Christ you know what it is it's like you
don't want to even [ __ ] think that
there's a whole bunch of people like
that out there you know and I really
believe if you get busted for that [ __ ]
that that that should just be it you
should be taken out back shot like a dog
in the street and then that is [ __ ] it
over you can't cure those [ __ ] people
and what they're doing and what they do
to people and the survivors of that how
that affects the person that they choose
to be with for the rest of their life
the what what you take from that [ __ ]
person can never be replaced and then
the the fallout of that what kind of
parent you're gonna be all of that it
just you know generations of therapy in
your family tree after that those
[ __ ] people should just that's it
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
that war criminals the whole [ __ ]
thing all of those [ __ ] people they
sit right in the street bang-bang over
all right ethical quandary dear Billy
baby daddy hey Bill I'll try to keep
this short and not interject with
anything other than the facts but I find
myself in a little bit of a moral crisis
that I'd like your opinion on and keep
it short because you don't read so good
all right read so well I think is what
you're supposed to say maybe you're not
I don't know all right
my fiance and I have been together for
five years and both are in our early 30s
she was in a serious relationship in
early 20s and engaged previously her
then partner was in law enforcement
they've been apart for almost 10 years
and he recently passed away after losing
a battle with some mental health issues
Jesus a couple weeks later we received a
notice in the mail that she is listed as
the beneficiary of his life-insurance
policy which is a significant amount of
money because of the good law
enforcement plans available
his family is unaware that he took out
this policy or that she is potentially
going to be benefitting it from it I see
three options one keep all the money to
give all the money to the family three
give the money to the family and keep a
little for ourselves as a processing fee
well why is this your decision it's not
your money it's it's her money you know
anyway she asked my opinion oh well she
asked your opinion all right my
apologies of what she could do and it's
a life-changing amount so it's very
difficult to say what I think someone
should do in that situation it's not
like we're returning a $20 bill you just
watched someone drop in front of you
who's to know if he left it that way on
purpose to his high school sweetheart
in the end it's up to her but can impact
both our lives so what do you think we
should do bill I should also know he did
have another girlfriend at the time of
his passing but no kids definitely would
have given it to them if they existed
were not monsters and his immediate
family our middle-class folk like
ourselves thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
dude I really don't know what to tell
you I mean he's an adult he made the
decision I'd say wait a second a couple
weeks ago a what did he pass away of
already forget with some mental health
issue I don't this you know what I would
do if you're thinking of giving some of
the money back I would make an anonymous
because these things get real messy real
fast and you're opening yourself up to
some sort of [ __ ] litigation he was
not in sound mind went up when he did
this and then you
to get a lawyer it's your heart is in
the right place but I really think
you're opening the door up to a [ __ ]
nightmare so if you want to make an
anonymous donation to their family
whatever that's what I would do I would
make an anonymous donation to the family
all right and I would leave it at that
to whatever amount you think but there
was no [ __ ] way I would give those
people my name and my [ __ ] address
and all of this [ __ ] cuz then the way
matter what you give them it won't be
enough this is this is just how people
are okay and it sounds like fiance is a
really special person that she cares
this much and is willing to do something
like that so she might have been the one
that got away with this guy and that's
why he never changed the beneficiary and
he was kind of loving the one he was
with with the new one forget and she
might come after well I was with him a
Bible above but you don't alright do not
give your [ __ ] name at all if you
give any of this [ __ ] money back to
them anonymously that's the way I would
do it okay
and I don't know how to [ __ ] do it
anonymously they'll [ __ ] fingerprint
it or whatever I have no idea you know I
would just leave it at that that's how I
would do it but do not give you [ __ ]
name or in that [ __ ] because you're
gonna open yourself up to some [ __ ]
litigation in a big goddamn headache
unless you're willing to be like alright
just take all the [ __ ] money I don't
give a [ __ ] because that would be the
quickest way out of it but myself I mean
that's why I would handle it we're suing
you alright [ __ ] it I quit I don't want
to be involved in that here here's all
the money Jesus Christ get away from me
alright jerking off in a sock okay go in
a completely different direction hey
Billy the wise I'm 17 years old and a
huge fan of everything you do I have a
question for you I'm not sure if it's a
generational thing but what's the deal
with jerking off into a sock is there a
benefit to it
did I advocate that I might have made a
joke about it I was never a gherkin off
into a sock I I'm not even sure it's
really a thing people do or just a joke
from the movies that somehow influence
carts culture
it seems really strange to jerk off into
anything you plan on wearing again I
would think you'd wear it again though I
would think just the way a dick is
shaped you know it's more convenient
this is a really gross [ __ ] subject
here anyway and it's the inside of the
sock how well could it be washed well
you turn it inside out without being
turned inside out which then puts okay
which then puts in contact with
everything else which defeats the
purpose of hiding it from your mom if
that's the point really reaching for
some rationale here bill thanks all
right okay so you jerked off into a sock
it's under your bed you don't know what
to do with it isn't that what's really
going on here [ __ ] I would say throw
it out but with DNA testing you don't
know where it's gonna end up and then
your Siemens at the [ __ ] site of some
crime okay so if there's a brook nearby
you should go down there and wash it on
a rock like some woman in the 1800s and
then light it on fire
now jerk off into some [ __ ] Kleenex
or whatever and then flush it there you
go
and always wear a condom all right
reunion hey Billy two dicks
I love the podcast thanks for making me
laugh on long road trips I have a
10-year old high school reunion coming
up ten year old I have a ten-year high
school reunion coming up and need your
advice the reunion is going to take
place at a bar and about 40 people are
attending that sounds like a great time
you're all still young 27 28 years old
29 for whoever stayed back this is a
good time I didn't have any negative
experiences in high school and I always
liked the people I
I went to school with no issue there my
wife on the AH
wife ad don't go to this thing my wife
on the other hand doesn't know these
people during her high school years at a
different school she didn't have such
positive memories she seems to be more
stressed about attending this thing than
I do
when we discussed it it seemed to be a
combination of not knowing anybody and
the fear of potentially bumping into
into another lady who I had had a thing
for 10 years ago I couldn't be any
further past those years and I believe
everyone will just act as adults well
you've never been to a reunion but my
wife seemed to make it about her and now
I don't want to and I don't want to say
to put her I don't know what to say to
put her at ease my first thing is can
you say that nicely alright usually we
have no problems chatting up a room as
strangers she is outgoing but super
nervous
which is odd well it sounds like she had
a real rough time growing up oh she had
a rough one okay I reminded her that
she's the only one for me and any
thoughts of seeing old flames is
superficial and made-up I never showed
any interest in communicating with these
people until this reunion I suggested
that if it's going to be this
uncomfortable I would like to go and
enjoy myself good man I'm still going
and she is the option of not going that
wasn't taken very well of course not I
would love for her to come and show her
off to everyone because she is so
amazing that's what you tell her but if
she's going to start [ __ ] over the whole
thing and ruin a potential great time to
see some old friend what's the point any
advice for me their heritage Billy breed
pork chops I would say that you want you
want to show her off you know that
doesn't make her feel well just say
listen I'm going to this thing and I'm
going to have
good time and you know your issues about
this are just that they're your issues I
wouldn't do this to you if you were
gonna go back to your high school
reunion I would come along and have a
good time I wouldn't want to ruin your
good time don't ruin my good time all
right I just feel like my boo boo boo
boo boo that's all your issues I've told
you how I felt about you I married you
for [ __ ] sakes and I want to go down
there and show you off all right this is
what you have to realize as an adult I
came to this Epiphany when I became a
parent okay and I had all these [ __ ]
fears and everything I had to come to
the Epiphany that my childhood does not
exist anymore okay neither does my
wife's childhood it just doesn't exist
anymore it still lives in between our
ears but it doesn't exist anymore
okay and our kid isn't is not my wife
okay and she's not me this is a
completely different person in a
completely different environment in a
completely different generation all
right
and if we want to drag some [ __ ] you
know out of the past the only way that's
gonna happen is we're gonna do it so it
doesn't exist all this [ __ ] that she's
[ __ ] worried about it doesn't even
exist anymore it lives in her [ __ ]
head head excuse me in her head all
right so that's it you know maybe she
needs to go talk to somebody
that she had such a bad time at high
school and you had such a good time that
she can't even go to your [ __ ] high
school reunion a high school she'd even
go to without [ __ ] superimposing her
own [ __ ] [ __ ] it's crazy say all
of that nicely
you know I'm proud
I want to show you off look at my
beautiful wife so this amazing person
that I married I don't know and
Security's not an attractive traits we
uh all right overrated underrated oh you
know the deal dude she would be able to
tell you to just [ __ ] get over it and
why are you gonna ruin my good time but
you have to doesn't work that way their
way you have to make sure you got a
[ __ ] good you know you got to do you
got a [ __ ] go the extra mile and
they'll never give you credit for it on
the view all right overrated /
underrated underrated people who keep
their mouths shut
exactly it's nice to have people around
who just enjoy the scenery yeah exactly
shut your [ __ ] yep check yeah yeah
maybe you'll learn something from the
guy who talks to himself for a [ __ ]
hour alright overrated people who never
talk or don't have opinions Wow okay I
get I see what you're doing here you
never know what they're thinking and
they never make decisions and you're
left wondering if they're pissed you
chose that restaurant
alright so people keep their mouths shut
it's nice to have okay so I see you
you've found the perfect woman that you
but you're having you know conflicted
feelings I love that she's not running
her Yap all the time but it would also I
would be nice to know that she does
think some things you dating a
Churchmouse there aren't you be careful
what you wish for
alright that is the podcast here
everybody if you're at work in your
board like I said go to MotoGP comm and
sign up it's not even that much money
and start watching some races it's
[ __ ] incredible absolutely incredible
alright I'll be at the punchline in San
Francisco tomorrow with Rose Bowl
tailgate legend
Joe bartnick who by the way was just in
Pittsburgh tearing things up at The
Improv with Paul virzi the
out there they're on tour they're
crushing it go see these guys they get
my stamp of approval both on and off
stage poop all right go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday